I am super thrilled to be with to my
favorite people to my favorite friends
to my favorite comedians and the hosts
of the crab feast podcast it's Jay
Larson and Ryan Sickler thank you good
to be here buddy the crab feast
well why don't what is that to people
who don't know the crab feast is a it's
a comedy podcast that focuses on
storytelling
I'm originally from Maryland Jays Boston
if you've ever been to a crab feast the
essence is sitting around with your
friends laughing telling old funny
stories right drinking some beers cuz
you get involved you're getting little
nibbles a crab every 30 minutes right
those bills those beers are gonna hit
you pretty fast actly
give me give me my v pills that I've
almost got the second clock cracked you
guys are a duo you you host a wonderful
were you going for me no I just know
what that we can hold them and that's a
little much that doesn't feel like a
romantic Oh head you know it doesn't
feel romantic to me doesn't look
romantic you know like you were hoping
it would turn you on it's not doing it
for Ryan Sickler you I call you the king
cuz you're my go-to example of what a
man should be Ju you push the boundaries
I am well you you're like me I'm 70% of
man 30% of lady I'd say I'm probably 70%
woman why are you 70% of lady cuz that
was raised by all women that was all
women around oh really
I was raised by all women he was raised
by his dad that's kind of but then I
didn't have a dad he didn't have a mom
it's kind of like a flip flop so we're
like to get we always say together we're
whole this isn't on lifetime this is TV
[Music]